jason brenheiser of the film is called  cubic  and the website uh  cubic the movie.com  so jason why did you make the film  well i was living in singapore actually  for a couple of years and uh i just  wanted to be making films while i was  there and i got together this indian  gentleman  who i met acting actually  and uh we decided to make a project  together and the  cubic came out of that  was there ever a point during the whole  filming process or editing where you  felt like giving up or it was just too  much things just went wrong  i would say definitely in  post-production uh we had a lot of  visual effects for this project and uh  we were planning on getting it done in  about four months it took uh over eight  months  so it was  it was rather tough at the end yeah how  did you secure funds um we actually  found a few investors in singapore that  were really interested in starting to  invest in film so this was their first  film to invest in